Herman Barnett: [In English] Spool 89, Spool 89, Spool 89, recording starts at about one minute. This is Herman Bernett.
David Boder: Geneva, August 28th. August 28th, 1946. The interviewee is Mrs. Malka Johles.
David Boder: [In German] Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Johles?
Malka Johles: Sechsundvierzig.
David Boder: [In English] Forty-six years old. Working in a shop for the training of knitting operations, knitting machine operations at the ORT in Geneva.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Frau Johles, ich wollt mich für Sie bitten, dass Sie mir in..., mit allen Einzelheiten, wie weit es geht, erzählen, was Ihnen passiert hat. Sie waren, haben in Wien gelebt, nicht wahr?
Malka Johles: Ja, im Wiener...
David Boder: Von der Zeit des Anschlusses.
Malka Johles: Von Wien nach Belgien?
David Boder: Ja. Also, Sie haben in Wien gelebt.
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, erzählen Sie mir, was haben Sie getan, wenn der Anschluss kam und was hat Ihnen passiert. Ganz langsam.
Malka Johles: [unverständlich] alles, ja...
David Boder: Und alles so. Wann hat der Anschluss, der Anschluss vorgebracht.
Malka Johles: Am 11. März.
David Boder: Welchem Jahr?
Malka Johles: ´38.
David Boder: In ´38.
Malka Johles: War mein Kind fünf Monate den Tag.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Malka Johles: Gerad’ auf den Tag. Hams uns gleich das Geschäft zugesperrt.
David Boder: Wie lange? Gleich den ersten Tag?
Malka Johles: Nein, den Montag, am 14. März, hamse uns das Geschäft zugesperrt.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Acht Tage. Dann hamses wieder aufgesperrt, natürlich.
David Boder: Aufgemacht.
Malka Johles: Aufgemacht. Nur, das Geschäft ist dann nicht mehr... Von der Minute an. Es ist niemand mehr hereingekommen.
David Boder: Warum?
Malka Johles: Weil er Angst gehabt hat.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Weil es ja ein Posten gestanden bei der Tür.
David Boder: Nun.
Malka Johles: SA.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Dass da niemand, äh, hereingehen, keine arischen Kunden.
David Boder: Ach, äh, arische Kunden. Haben Sie bevor arische Kunden, äh...
Malka Johles: Nein, jüdische Kunden hab’ ich keine gehabt.
David Boder: Ah, Sie haben. Was für ein Geschäft war das?
Malka Johles: Delikatessen. Alles.
David Boder: Es waren Delikatessen. Und sie hat, ja...
Malka Johles: Lebensmittel, alles.
David Boder: Und Sie haben meistens christliche...
Malka Johles: Nur christliche...
David Boder: Nur christliche Kunden.
David Boder: Also, ist ein Posten gestanden, dass Christen nicht reinkommen konnten.
Malka Johles: Und, und niemand hereingeht...
David Boder: Und wie ist das Geschäft weitergegangen?
Malka Johles: Ist nicht mehr gegangen.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie ein bisschen lauter. Ist nicht mehr ...?
Malka Johles: Nicht mehr gegangen. Von dem Moment an...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Ist es nicht mehr gegangen.
David Boder: Nun?
Malka Johles: Nun, hab’ ich...
David Boder: Was haben Sie dann gemacht?
Malka Johles: Hab ich interessiert, die ganze Zeit um wegzufahren, selbstverständlich, hab’ ich mich angestellt, von einem Konsulat zum anderen, dann hab’ ich bekommen eine [unverständlich] im Mai...
David Boder: Von wo?
Malka Johles: Von meinem Cousin, gewissen Kölsch, Pharmazist, im äh,
David Boder: Br...
Malka Johles: Bronx.
David Boder: In Bronx.
Malka Johles: Bronx, ja, mein Cousin ist das. Kölsch, Harry Kölsch.
David Boder: Nun?
Malka Johles: Nun, da haben wir gewartet, und gewartet und dann am Zehnt... Am, äh, Siebenundzwanzigsten. Oktober nach meinen Mann abgeführt nach Bonj...nach Bonjui.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Weil er einen, äh, richtig, einen, äh, einen, äh, gültigen Reisepass gehabt hat als polnischer Staatsbürger und da war er bis zum 2. November. Am 2. November kam er zurück.
David Boder: Nach Wien.
Malka Johles: Ja, nach Wien zurück. Über Berlin.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Es ist eine Amnestie gekommen und er wird, äh, zurückkommen.
Malka Johles: Am 10. November ist uns eingedrungen, vielleicht zwanzig Gestapo-Männer, haben mir alles ausgetragen, den ganzen Schmuck, das ganze Silber, alles weggetragen.
David Boder: Nun?
Malka Johles: Meinen Mann hat man unterwegs eingesperrt.
David Boder: Was heißt “unterwegs”?
Malka Johles: Unterwegs. Nicht von zu Hau, nicht zu Hause. Er war nicht, äh, momentan zu Hause am 10. November ´38.
David Boder: ´38.
Malka Johles: Weil, nun, er hat sich geflüchtet zu einem Fleischhacker, einen jüdischen Fleischhacker, gewissen Gruber. Hat man ihn eingesperrt samt seinen Jungen und meinen Mann. Meinen Mann hat man in, bis in die Früh gehalten...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Zum elften, äh, November, früh, weil er doch einen gültigen Reisepass gehabt hat...
Malka Johles: Konnt‘ er zurückkommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und da waren wir bis zum 14. Dezember in Wien.
Malka Johles: 14. Dezember sind wir geflüchtet nach Belgien...
David Boder: Also warten Sie mal. Man ist zu Ihnen gekommen...
Malka Johles: Am 10. November um zwölf Uhr. Man hat mir alles...
David Boder: Bei Tag oder bei Nacht?
Malka Johles: Bei Tag.
David Boder: Bei Tag.
Malka Johles: Man hat mir aufgetragen, [unverständlich] für 24 Personen...ich mein das ist doch nicht wichtig.
David Boder: Ja, das ist sehr wichtig.
Malka Johles: Ja. Eine (unverständlich, klingt wie „Kanteste“) von für vierundzwanzig Persön, Personen. Silber. Und, Schmuck von, von,äh, von mir und von meinem Mann, natürlich. Es war ein groß, sehr großen Wert...
David Boder: Ja, und?
Malka Johles: Na, und Kleider und so hat er von uns nicht...
David Boder: Und was haben die gesagt?
Malka Johles: Die haben gesagt, das kommt, äh, hab` ich gezeigt einen Schein von der Devisenzentrale, dass ich hab` das deponiert, dass nicht, äh, sondern nur angegeben...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Weil ich gedacht hab’, ich komm schon im, äh, August nach Amerika.
Malka Johles: Wollt` ich doch hinausziehen, hab` ich das bei der Vermögensstelle, bei der Devisenzentrale angegeben.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Dreitausend Schilling den Wert.
Malka Johles: Und, das hab` ich gezeigt, dass ich das zu regelmäß, -recht angemeldet habe...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Ja und da haben (Band unterbrochen)....Fiche ist nichts wert, sie nehmen ihn jetzt weg...
David Boder: Fiche, das Papier, das nicht...
Malka Johles: Das Papier von der Devisenzentrale ist nichts, sondern, ich hab’s durch einen Anwalt, durch einen Doktor Scherlach
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Einen Anwalt Scherlach machen lassen, hab` bezahlt 150 Mark für die, für die, wahrscheinlich für die Spesen. Und da haben sie gesagt, das nicht, nützt nichts, hab` auch gesagt, wir sind polnische Staatsbürger, hat er gesagt, da, äh, wann wir wegfahren werden nach Amerika, dann werden wir’s zurückbekommen. Ich hab` mich überall umgeschaut, bin am polnischen Konsulat gegangen sofort, und da haben sie gesagt, sie können nichts machen.
David Boder: Also? Nun? Was, was war den Zehnten?
Malka Johles: 10. November?
David Boder: Und dann?
Malka Johles: Nun, dann, äh, bin ich gegangen nach, sind wir gegangen nach Belgien weg.
David Boder: Wie... Warum sind sie nach Belgien gegangen?
Malka Johles: Weil es hat geheissen, wir sollen nicht, wir sollen doch nicht bleiben, trotzdem mein Mann hat, hat bis zum 31er Jahr einen polnischen gültigen Pass gebraucht, und dann haben sie gesagt, dass er sie doch nicht braucht und,
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Es wird immer, immer schlimmer werden.
David Boder: Hat man Sie nach Belgien fahren lassen?
Malka Johles: Nein, nein, wir sind illegal mit den Kindern...
David Boder: Also, Sie sind mit welchem, mit dem, mit dem Kleinen...
Malka Johles: Mit dem kleinen Kind, der war also dann nur 13 Monate...
David Boder: Und wo war der Junge?
Malka Johles: Der ist auch mit uns!
David Boder: Aha.
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: Also, erzählen Sie mal, wie sind Sie von Wien nach Belgien rübergekommen?
Malka Johles: Wie wir gekommen sind? Wir sind gefahren nach Aachen.
David Boder: Nach Deu .... In Deutschland.
Malka Johles: Ja. Köln. Aachen.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Nun, da sind wir hinein zu der Gestapo.
Malka Johles: Und, wir sind untersucht worden.
David Boder: Man hat sie, sie sind selbst hineingegangen, oder man hat sie...reingeführt?
Malka Johles: Nein, nein, wir sind hineinge...wir haben doch müssen durch...durchgehen durch’s Kontrollhaus...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und das war doch mit der Gestapo.
Malka Johles: Mein Mann ist untersucht worden, wir haben natürlich gesagt, ob, ob er irgend.., ob er nicht etwas da hat eingenäht, da hat mein Mann gesagt, wenn sie wollen, können sie den Rock aufschneiden....ich habe nix drinnen. Hat er nur gehabt einige bissl Windeln von der Klein, vom Kind, nicht wahr? Und da hat er alles durchgestöbert. Auch das Kind ist untersucht worden, mein Junge. Ich separat, mein Junge separat, mein Mann separat.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und dann sind wir gegangen. Und da haben wir überall gefragt, da hat man uns gesagt, wir sollen, da und da haben wir jemand, ja. Da sind wir hineingekommen durch ein Kaffeehaus. Da waren wir etliche Tage.
Malka Johles: Das war aber eine schreckliche Kälte damals...und da hat uns die, die, die, den Kaffeehaus verschafft ein Auto.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Das Auto ist gekommen, natürlich. Und da sind wir gefahren, drei Stunden mit dem Auto nach, bis nach Brüssel.
David Boder: Und, Sie sind die gänzlich illegalen Regeln gegangen?
Malka Johles: Ja, illegal.
David Boder: Hat die Gestapo gewusst, dass Sie illegal...
Malka Johles: Ja, das haben die gewusst!
David Boder: Und das haben Sie
Malka Johles: Das haben die Gestapo...
David Boder: Sie haben denen gesagt, Sie flüchten.
Malka Johles: Wir gehen, ja, ja. Wir gehen.
David Boder: Wir gehen nach Belgien...
Malka Johles: Nach Belgien, ja.
David Boder: Nach Belgien, und die haben gesagt, das kümmert uns nicht, Sie können gehen.
Malka Johles: Haben uns hinausgelassen und wir sind weitergegangen.
David Boder: Aha.
Malka Johles: Natürlich in der finsteren Nacht. Wir sind gekommen nach Brüssel, war eine grimmige Kälte, eine, eine, die Kleine hat das Wangerl abgefroren. Da musst ich dreimal in der Woche, auf dreimal der Woche auf in Krish, äh, hat`s Bestrahlungen bekommen, dass das zurückgeht, äh, bis das Kind, wir sind soweit gegangen. Durch die
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Durch die größte Kälte. Haben nichts mitgehabt. Gar nichts. Da friert das Kind.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: Was haben Sie jetzt... Ist das Kind?
Malka Johles: Dann ist das Kind, äh, geheilt worden.
David Boder: Also Sagen Sie, die Frau hat Sie dann, ein Auto besorgt, und das Auto hat Sie rübergeschmuggelt.
Malka Johles: Rübergeschmuggelt.
David Boder: Haben Sie viel bezahlen müssen?
Malka Johles: Das kann ich mich nicht erinnern. Das...
David Boder: Hat die Gestapo Sie rausgelassen mit etwas oder haben die?
Malka Johles: Wir haben nur zehn Mark, die haben, wir haben nichts gerettet! Weder. Wir haben gar nichts...kein Geld.
David Boder: Keinen Schmuck, gar nichts.
Malka Johles: Schmuck, haben sie uns alles weggenommen, alles, am 10. November.
David Boder: Wie hat das getan? Wie hat das Auto bezahlt?
Malka Johles: Wir haben schon wahrscheinlich etwas, mein Mann hat schon bezahlt...wir haben doch 10 Mark jeder bekommen, bekommen.
David Boder: Ach, jeder zehn Mark.
Malka Johles: Jeder zehn Mark. Ja.
David Boder: So waren Sie vier Personen...
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: Da waren es vierzig Mark.
Malka Johles: Vierzig Mark.
David Boder: Und wohin sind Sie nach Brüssel hingekommen?
Malka Johles: Nach Brüssel zum Komitee.
David Boder: Zum jüdischen Komitee.
Malka Johles: Ja. Und da haben wir bekommen Unterstützung gleich.
David Boder: Und in Brüssel, die Regierung hat Sie nicht zurückschicken wollen?
Malka Johles: Nein, nein, nein.
David Boder: Es gab kein...
Malka Johles: Wir haben keinen Anstand gehabt.
David Boder: Keinen Umstand?
Malka Johles: Niemals. Nein.
David Boder: So. Nun? Und so, wie lange waren Sie in Brüssel?
Malka Johles: In Brüssel, bis zum, äh, bis zum, äh, 12. Mai 1940.
David Boder: Bis zum 12. Mai 1940.
Malka Johles: Ja. 40 sind wir geflüchtet nach, äh, nach, äh, Frankreich...
David Boder: Warum?
Malka Johles: Warum? Weil der Krieg ist ausgebrochen.
David Boder: Nun? Und die Deutschen sind gekommen nach, nach Belgien...
Malka Johles: Die Deutschen sind... Da waren wir noch nicht, wir waren, wir sind noch weggeflüchtet, da waren noch die, äh, die Belgier.
David Boder: Ja. Und hat man Sie nach Frankreich reingelassen?
Malka Johles: Ja, wir sind eingestiegen, wir haben Billeten gekauft nach Paris, und da, man konnte aber nicht aussteigen, man ist direkt gefahren bis nach Tou..., äh, Toulouse. Bis...Toulouse.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Eine große Stadt.
Malka Johles: In Südfrankreich.
David Boder: Und warum durfte man nicht in Paris aussteigen?
Malka Johles: Dort ist überhaupt, der Zug hat, ist überhaupt nicht ausgestiegen, nicht eingestiegen, niemand. Von Brüssel direkt bis nach Toulouse.
David Boder: Nach Toulouse.
Malka Johles: Da war schon so eine, äh, eine, ein so einer Zug.
David Boder: Waren da viele Flüchtlinge dort?
Malka Johles: Ja! Sehr viele!
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter.
Malka Johles: Sehr viele.
David Boder: Sehr viele...
Malka Johles: Flämer, äh, äh, Waloner, Juden, verschiedene, verschiedene Leute.
David Boder: Und warum/was sind die Waloner?
Malka Johles: Waloner. Waloner, Franzosen. Waren, auch Flämer!
David Boder: Flämer waren da.
Malka Johles: Flämer waren auch sehr viele...
David Boder: Warum sind sie, warum [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Die haben auch nicht wollen.
David Boder: Also, die haben einfach nicht...
Malka Johles: Die haben Angst gehabt, wieder vor dem Krieg, vielleicht, nicht? Die das erlebt haben und...[unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja. So sind Sie nach Toulouse gekommen. Was hat dann passiert?
Malka Johles: Ja, in Toulouse da sind wir einquartiert worden in die Dörfer.
David Boder: Bei wem?
Malka Johles: [unverständlich] Bewohner? In, äh, einquartiert. Da man jeden Haus, haben wir da...
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: ...Reingekommen...der maire, der Bürgermeister...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und da waren wir dort bis, äh, äh, acht Tage.
Malka Johles: Acht Tage mussten wir, äh, nach Toulouse kommen, die Stadion.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Mein Mann. Und ich. Und die, äh, meine beide Kinder. Mich hat man zurückgeschickt.
David Boder: Nach Toulouse?
Malka Johles: Und meine Kin..., äh, zurück ins Dorf. Und mein Mann hat, äh, ist interniert worden.
David Boder: Oh! Ihr Mann ist...
Malka Johles: Ja. Mein Mann ist als polnischer Staatsbürger trotzdem interniert worden.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, wo?
Malka Johles: Ist nicht mehr zurückgekommen, mein Mann. Ja, er ist schon zurückgekommen, nachher. Mein Mann ist gekommen dann nach Cyprien.Saint-Cyprien im Département Pyrénées Orientales1
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Cyprien, das ist bei der, äh, bei der, äh, bei der, äh, spanische Grenze.
Malka Johles: Ja. Cyprien. Und ich hab`, war im Dorf, dort und bin unterstützt worden von der Regierung in dem Dorf, mit meinen zwei Kindern...
David Boder: Nicht von dem jüdischen Komitee?
Malka Johles: Nein, nein, direkt von wo alle bekommen haben.
David Boder: Was hat die Regierung Ihnen gegeben?
Malka Johles: Ich hab` bekommen, ich konnte, ich meine...
David Boder: Sie konnten eben leben.
Malka Johles: Ja, und äh, äh, viel hab` ich nicht brauchen zahlen.
David Boder: Haben Sie probiert, zu arbeiten?
Malka Johles: Nu, wie hätte ich, das Kind war doch nicht einmal zwei Jahre. Was hätte ich da...?
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Mein Junge hat schon ein etwas geholfen, ein bisschen.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Malka Johles: Dann bin ich gefahren nach Cyprien. Am 18. Juli. Und da konnte ich meinen Mann gleich mit herausbekommen von Cyprien.
David Boder: Wie haben Sie das...?
Malka Johles: Weil er polnischer Staatsbürger war.
David Boder: Aha.
Malka Johles: Den hätten sie sollen gar nicht internieren.
Malka Johles: Mein Mann hätte gar nicht (unverständlich, klingt wie „Gebühren“) gehabt, [unverständlich] um nach Toulouse zu fahren. Aber die Gendarme sind gekommen von, äh, von Toulouse und haben gesagt zu jedem muss sich registrieren. Und weil wir halt polnischer Staatsbürger gewesen sind, zurückschicken. Aber leider, haben Sie nicht von (unverständlich, klingt wie Stadion) nicht zurückgeschickt, sondern nur mich und meine zwei Kinder.
David Boder: Nun? Und nachher haben sie Ihren... So, wie lange war Ihr Mann interniert?
Malka Johles: Interniert war mein Mann bis zum 18. Juli. Vom 17. Mai bis zum 18. Juli.
David Boder: Ja. Nun? Was hat dann passiert? Wir haben...
Malka Johles: Dann ist mein Mann, dann waren wir bis zum September, in dem Dorf. Mein Mann hat gearbeitet dort für die Bäuerin.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und, äh, und, da war, dann sind wir gekommen in ein Lager.
David Boder: Warum?
Malka Johles: Nach Brens In ein Familienlager.Brens, im Département Tarn2
David Boder: Warum sind Sie dort hingekommen?
Malka Johles: Weil das Dorf hat, äh, die [unverständlich] wollte nicht mehr halten.
David Boder: Aha.
Malka Johles: Keine Unterstützung wahrscheinlich mehr geben.
David Boder: Wieso?
Malka Johles: Und die, die jüdische Communauté angeblich, hat das Lager gegründet.
David Boder: Oh, und das war...
Malka Johles: In Brens. Ja. Brens, das war bei Albi, bei Goier.Evtl.Gaillac3 Ich weiß nicht, Sie werden kennen die Gegend...
David Boder: Ja. Ja. [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Ja, das kann man sehen. Brens. Und dort waren wir bis zum 4. Februar, äh, ´41.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und dann sind wir geflüchtet. Nach [unverständlich]
David Boder: Warum?
Malka Johles: Äh, vom Dorf sind wir nach Lyon geflüchtet.
David Boder: Warum hatten Sie...?
Malka Johles: Warum? Weil, weil wir, man hat gesagt, man schickt weg, nach [Rivesaltes?]. Und nach [Milles?] Und richtig. Wir sind am Vierten weg, und am sechsten sind wir gekommen nach Lyon, und am achtzehnten..., äh, Februar hat man weggeschickt, die alleinstehenden Personen nach [Milles?] Und die mit Familien, mit Kinder nach [Rivesaltes?].
David Boder: Und wo waren Sie?
Malka Johles: Wir waren in Lyon.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Wir kamen nach Lyon, hat der Herr Pauler. Gesagt, das war ein (unverständlich, evtl. „Elsässer“), ein [unverständlich] hat er gesagt, äh, zu einem gewissen Deutsch, der (unverständlich, evtl. „weg“) gefahren nach Amerika im einundvierziger Jahr. Herr Deutsch, nehmen Sie raus die Liste, die vier, die Familie Johles kommt auch von Brens. Die haben, äh, wir gesagt, wir kommen nicht von Brenz, wir kommen von Brenteau.
Malka Johles: Wir haben, äh, äh, wollen verleugnen. Weil, die, was von Brens gekommen sind, wollten sie keine Unterstützung geben. Und da hat er gesagt, also, die eine Woche bekommen sie, und bis wir die Liste bekommen, dass sie wirklich nicht von Brens gekommen sind, so, bekommen sie keine Unterstützung. Da hat mein Mann gesagt, machen Sie was Sie wollen. Mein Kind hat, äh, Fieber gehabt, Mittelohrentzündung und trotzdem sind wir geflüchtet. Nach, nach Lyon. Weil wir eben, äh, erfahren haben, dass man wird wegschicken. Dann mussten wir eben mit dem Kind, mit Mittelohrentzündung wegfahren. Und, da sind wir gekommen, haben wir gehabt sehr Schwierigkeiten. Nicht mit dem Aufenthalt, sondern mit der Unterstützung.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Ja. Und wie man hat aufgelöst das Brens.
Malka Johles: Also konnten Sie das nicht mehr drohen, da haben sie uns schon regelrecht die Unterstützung gegeben.
David Boder: Also, Sie haben nicht gewollt, dass die Leute von Brens weggehen.
Malka Johles: Von Brens weg..., weil wir haben die Toulouser communauté, wahrscheinlich, oder ich weiß nicht, oder die Marseiller, ha...haben angeblich das Lager ge...gekauft oder oder gebaut. Das soll angeblich eine Million Francs gekostet haben.
David Boder: Gekostet haben. Nun?
Malka Johles: Und da wollten sie nicht die Leute dort, sie wollten, dass wir kommen nach Kiew. Und die sollen dort umkommen, in Kiew.
David Boder: Nun?
Malka Johles: Und dann, äh, da waren wir dort, natürlich in Lyon. Da haben wir müssen leben von der Unterstützung, es war sehr, sehr spärlich, selbstverständlich. Aber, am 16. März hat man meinen Mann einkonferiert, weggenommen von der Arbeit.
David Boder: Wer hat das getan?
Malka Johles: Die Regierung.
David Boder: [unverständlich] die (Vichy-)Regierung.
Malka Johles: Die Präfektia.Gemeint ist wohl die Präfektur, da in Frankreich der préfet der Präfekt des Départements ist.4
David Boder: Die Präfektia.
Malka Johles: Die Präfektia hat meinen Mann geholfen, in der Früh, und hat ihn eingesperrt, und dann haben sie ihn geschickt in ein so ein Sammellager, Chapeaulis. Das war eine Vorstadt vor Lyon. Und [unverständlich] haben sie ihn gehalten von Montag bis Samstag. Samstag ist er gekommen in die Haute Savoie.Hochsavoyen5
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Da ist er ein..., da ist er eingeoperiert geworden. Nach Haute-Savoie.... Und da hat er nicht nur die Bergarbeit unter die [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: [unverständlich], sehr, sehr hoch.
David Boder: Wie alt war er denn?
Malka Johles: War, mein Mann war damals einundvierzig Jahre.
David Boder: Aha. Nun?
Malka Johles: Und da ist er gekommen, ab und zu ist er gekommen nach Urlaub nach Lyon...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und wie es ist gekommen die Raten im August....
David Boder: Was ist “die Raten”?
Malka Johles: Na, wie man hat, äh, die, die, die, nun, die ...deportierte Menschen..
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Im August ´42.
Malka Johles: Hat man natürlich das Lager schon, welche Leute da, äh, nicht Umstand geworden, vor lauter [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und da hat mein Mann sofort telefoniert meine Junge, am 22. August, also er soll sofort kommen.
Malka Johles: Mein Junge ist gekommen. Mein Mann konnte doch nichts machen, weil er doch schon...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Äh, er war doch schon eingeschlossen, in dem Kampf. Aber mein Junge war noch kein Junge mit 15 Jahre und da ist er reingegangen zum Kommandanten und hat angefangen zu bitten und zu weinen und das hat schon, mein Mann wollte sich schon lang operieren lassen auf den Leistenbruch, aber in Lyon. Und der Kommandant hat gesagt, nein er will nur in St.Julien wo das Lager dazugehört.St. Julien-en-Genevois6
Malka Johles: Die Gr..., wissen Sie, die Präfektia... Hat dort gehabt
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: ... Ein so Hospital und das, äh, das Lager [unverständlich] der Kampf, Arbeiter, äh, hat mein Mann gesagt, nein, in St. Julien lass ich mich nicht operieren, ich möchte gerne in Lyon, wo ich meine Frau hab`, und mir was passiert, da hat er gesagt, er kann nichts machen, und hat angesucht bei der Präfektia...Ja, und da nach Lyon sind sie auch zu mir gekommen, ein paar Mal von der Präfektia. das ist von der Regierung. Ich soll Unterstützung nehmen. Hab ich gesagt, ich nehm` keine. Sie wollten mir geben für meine Kinder und für mich, Unterstützung.
David Boder: Warum?
Malka Johles: Weil mein Mann hat doch dort gearbeitet.
David Boder: Aha.
Malka Johles: Er hat doch, äh, ein[unverständlich].
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Er hat doch regelrecht gearbeitet.
David Boder: Ja. Und sie wollten Ihnen nun Unterstützung geben.
Malka Johles: Ja, ein Arbeiter, äh, [unverständlich] travailleur étranger, hat es doch geheissen. Hab ich abgesagt, weil ich habe Angst gehabt, vor denen Unterstützung zu nehmen. Also, wie, äh, wie die das [unverständlich] mein Junge herein anfängt zu weinen und zu bitten den Kommandanten, und ob mein Mann könnte nicht, eventuell, operiert werden.
David Boder: Hmm.
Malka Johles: Also hat der, der sofort telefoniert den, den Doktor von St. Julien und da ist gekommen der Doktor am Vierundzwanzigsten. Montag. Und, äh, hat meinen Mann erklärt, dass er ist krank und hat ihn mitgenommen mit dem, mit seinem Auto nach St. Julien. Hat ihn die Gestap, nicht die Gestapo, sondern die (unverständlich; evtl. „Cavalerie“) hat ihn herausgelassen. Wann der Doktor vom Spital, äh, festgesetzt hat, dass der Mann hat Fieber und er muss operiert wurden. Am Vierundzwanzigsten ist mein Mann operiert wurden und hat er sich müssen [unverständlich] gelegen in St. Julien. Das war an der Grenze, das ist da bei, wenn man vom jüdischen Friedhof herauskommt, von Genf, grenzt das an das Spital, an St. Julien.
David Boder: Das ganze in der Schweiz.
Malka Johles: Das ist direkt an der Schweiz, ich meine. Nicht weit.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Wenn man geht vom Spital in den Garten, kann man schon, ist man schon an der Grenze.
David Boder: Nun.
Malka Johles: An der Schweizer Grenze. Dort ist mein Mann operiert geworden, das Leistenbruch. Mein Junge, der kann ja perfekt französisch...Natürlich ich wusste nicht, wo der Junge ist. Er hat mir schon ein Telegramm aufgegeben, dass mein Mann Gott sei Dank im Spital ist.
David Boder: Hm.
Malka Johles: Und dass er nicht im Kampf ist. Und, dass er operiert worden, wann er zurück kommt, mein Junge, hat er telegraphiert, weiß er nicht. Ich bin nicht weggegangen. Ich hab` mich nicht versteckt. Äh, ich hab` mir gedacht, sie haben mich vielleicht nicht, doch nicht suchen, weil es war eingetragen, dass mein Mann...arbeitet.
David Boder: Arbeitet.
Malka Johles: Ja. Und die Kleine war noch erst viereinhalb Jahre. Da bin ich eben nicht weggegangen. Weil ich gedacht hab`, mein Junge kommt und der wird nicht wissen, wo ich bin.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und mein Ma..., Junge war drei Tage in St. Julien und nicht gemeldet.
Malka Johles: Im Hotel. Die war sehr gentile, die Frau hat den Lappen nicht gemeldet.Mit „Lappen“ meint Frau Johles evtl. den sogenannten „Judenpass“ oder „Judenausweis“. (Anmerk.d. R) 7 Und dann hat sie gesagt, sie kann nicht, sie muss ihn doch anmelden, weil es kommt Kontrolle von der Polizei. Und wie sie ihn angemeldet hat, und wie mein Junge hinausgeht vom Spital, vom Besuch, die Besuchszeit aus war, ist gestanden drei Gendarmenristen. Und haben den Jungen eingesperrt. Auf der Kommissariat, haben gesagt, „du bist eingetragen, du schlafst dort im Hotel, was machst du da?“ Sagt mein Junge, „wie sie sehen, ich bin ja für meinen Papa...“ „Na, was machst du da? Was braucht dich der Papa, wann er im Hospital“...Sagt er, „mein Papa kann kein Wort französisch, und da wollt ich halt dabei sein, dass damit mein Papa irgendetwas versteht“. Also, sagen sie, „was, was geschieht jetzt mit dir?“ Sagt mein Junge, „ich möchte gerne zu meiner Mutter, nach Lyon zurück“. Sagt er, „so! Deine Mama ist schon längst weg, so wie alle Juden. Sind schon alle zusammengefangen, und was machen wir jetzt mir dir?“ Also, der Junge hat angefangen, sehr bitterlich zu weinen. Er hatte Angst gehabt, sie werden ihn deportieren. Hat der einer gesagt, der einer, äh, war ein Älterer.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: So ein Kommissär. Hat er gesagt, „wein’ nicht“, sagt er, „ich habe selber vier [unverständlich], das heisst, vier Kinder zu Hause, ich tu dir nichts“. Sagt er, „ich tu dir gar nichts, Junge, wein’ nicht und beruhige dich, wann du glaubst, dass deine Mutter noch in Lyon zum antreffen ist, gib halt ein Telegramm auf und, äh, und fahr, äh, und fahr“. Also, ich hab’ ein Telegramm bekommen, dass mein Junge...
David Boder: Kommt.
Malka Johles: Kommt. Ich ha, hat, hatte Angst gehabt, zu gehen zu der....
David Boder: Bahn.
Malka Johles: Bahn. Es war doch sehr gefährlich. Also hab’ ich gewartet unterm Gebüsch, ich hab’ gewusst, zu dieser Zeit kommt er an, jetzt hab’ ich gewartet. Ich hab’ gepfiffen und er hat gepfiffen und so haben wir uns zu erkennen gegeben. Und zwar um ein Uhr bei der Nacht.
David Boder: Er hat gepfiffen?
Malka Johles: Ja. Ich konnte nicht rein...
David Boder: Haben Sie da eine bestimmte Melodie gehabt?
Malka Johles: Ja. Er hat schon gewusst.
David Boder: Was war das?
Malka Johles: Naja, so, irgendetwas gepfiffen direkt und da hat er schon mich erkannt. Und da ist er zurückgekommen, hat mir erzählt, dass mein Mann ist operiert worden, und die wollten ihn einsperren und so, und von dieser Stunde an, natürlich, haben wir nicht mehr zu Hause geschlafen. Und da haben wir uns bei einer Nachbarin geschlafen. Dann ist mein Junge noch einmal gefahren zu meinem Mann besuchen. Ist ihm schon etwas besser gegangen. Und dann ist mein Junge noch einmal rausgefahren in den Kampf. Das...ist ja nicht wichtig.
David Boder: Was heißt “in den Kampf”?
Malka Johles: In, in [unverständlich], wo mein Mann war, ist...
David Boder: Ja, ja, das ist alles sehr wichtig. Alles wichtig...
Malka Johles: Ja. Und weil das Lager noch besti..., bestanden ist,
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und mein Mann wusste ja nicht, was er machen soll...
Malka Johles: Die, die Schwester, die Krankenschwester hat zwar gesagt, mein Mann, wann er dann, dann im St. Marien-[unverständlich] wann er denn kann soweit aufstehen, möchte sie ihm durchsehen, dass er auf der Grenze kommt.
David Boder: Nach der Schweiz.
Malka Johles: Nach der Schweiz. Hat er gesagt, ich kann doch nicht allein gehen, ich hab’ ja zwei Kinder, und, und eine Frau. Was soll ich da machen? Und ich Hab’ mich ja doch nicht getraut, nach St. Julien zu fahren, weil man hat doch von der Autopiste heruntergenommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Also jetzt ist mein Mann, äh, ist mein Junge gefahren zu den, äh, Lagerkommandanten und hat herausgenommen eine, eine, eine, einen, äh, Krankenurlaub für einen Monat. Und mit dem Krankenurlaub ist er gefahren ins Spital...
Malka Johles: Mein Junge, und hat meinen Mann nach Haus genommen nach Lyon. Also, äh, schwer krank war er noch. Und, also [unverständlich], nicht mit der Operation, sondern das Ganze da.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Ist gekommen. Und da waren wir ein paar Tage.
Malka Johles: Mein Mann hat doch gehabt, äh, einen Krankenurlaub vom Spital und zugleich noch vom, vom Kampf.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Also, das hat separat gekostet [unverständlich], und, aber auch haben wir uns versteckt. Und da sind wir...und da hat mein Mann gesagt, er traut sich nicht, er bleibt nicht, samt den, samt dieser Krankenurlaubs bleib ich trotzdem nicht. Und da haben wir uns entschlossen, und wir sind in Gottes Namen gefahren.
David Boder: Wohin?
Malka Johles: Auf der Grenze dort.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und, äh, wir sind glücklich herübergekommen.
David Boder: Herübergekommen.
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, wie Sie rübergekommen sind, äh...?
Malka Johles: Waren wir im [unverständlich], da...
David Boder: Also, wer hat Sie jetzt getroffen, wenn Sie rübergekommen sind?
Malka Johles: Bei den [unverständlich].
David Boder: Hier bei, in der G..., bei Genf?
Malka Johles: Ja, bei Genf, ja.
David Boder: Ja, nun? Wo sind Sie da gewesen?
Malka Johles: Da waren wir in so einem Auffangslager, nur eine Nacht.
David Boder: Das war am Anfang...
Malka Johles: Nur eine Nacht, ja.
David Boder: Haben die Sie nicht zurückschicken wollen?
Malka Johles: Nein, das Kind war ja noch nicht....
David Boder: Was.
Malka Johles: Das war, das Kind war ja noch nicht fünf Jahre.
David Boder: Aha. So, hat man die [unverständlich].
Malka Johles: Ja. Die haben uns nicht beanständet. Eine Familie haben sie zurückgeschickt.
David Boder: Warum?
Malka Johles: Vor uns. Weil sie, es war gerade, da haben sie gesagt, der Stichtag damals.
David Boder: Was?
Malka Johles: Es war, eine, ein, es war ein, äh, ein, ein Tag, das man hat, äh...
David Boder: Zurückgeschickt.
Malka Johles: Zurückgeschickt. Es waren, er war dreiundzwanzig Jahren, zwei ältere Leute.
David Boder: Aha.
Malka Johles: Haben sie zurückgeschickt. Aber die sind nach, äh, nach vier Mal sind sie herübergegangen und sind doch gekommen. Jetzt sind sie schon in Chelles (unklar).
David Boder: Wo?
Malka Johles: Die Chelles. Die arbeiten...
David Boder: Wo ist das?
Malka Johles: Chelles, bei Paris.
David Boder: Oh.
Malka Johles: Ja. Es geht ihnen sehr gut. Uns hat man nicht, äh...
David Boder: Nun? So sind nach der Schweiz rübergekommen, in welchem Jahr?
Malka Johles: In welchem Jahr? ´42. Am 27. Dezember.
David Boder: ´42.
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: Und dann was hat man mit Ihnen sofort getan?
Malka Johles: Was man hat mit uns getan?
David Boder: Ja, wo hat man Sie....
Malka Johles: Da sind wir gewesen einen Tag
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: In dem Auffangslager. Dann sind wir gekommen am Territorial...
Malka Johles: Territorialkommando. Und dann hat man uns im Hotel einquartiert. Man hat uns gegeben Unterstützung.
David Boder: Die jüdische schweizerische Gruppe?
Malka Johles: Erst das communauté. Ja, ich weiß nicht genau. Die communauté...
David Boder: Ist das ein jüdisches Komm...
Malka Johles: Ein jüdisches, ja! Und dann haben wir bekommen aber vom polnischen Konsulat, in einem Monat herum, im Oktober, äh, haben wir schon bekommen, äh, direkt von polnischen Konsulat.
David Boder: Warum vom Konsulat?
Malka Johles: Weil mein Mann eben polnischer Staatsbürger war.
David Boder: Sie waren nicht von Polen?
Malka Johles: (Schweigt)
David Boder: Sie sind nicht in Polen...
Malka Johles: Ich bin von Polen geboren. Weil polnisch war. Mein Mann auch.
David Boder: Also, also waren Sie beide polnische Staatsbürger?
Malka Johles: Ja. Ja. Nur ha, mein Ma... , mein Pass hat man weggenommen in Wien...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Wie der Hitler gekommen und mein Mann hat seinen Pass gehabt, verlängert bevor der Hitler gekommen, hat er ge...sich noch
Malka Johles: ...auszeichnen können, dass er äh, äh...
David Boder: Und die Polen haben Sie dann unterstützt?
Malka Johles: Unterstützt. Ja. Bis zum März ´43.
David Boder: Ja. Nun? Was hat dann passiert?
Malka Johles: Dann, äh, im März ´43, hat es, waren sehr Schwierigkeiten, ist mein Junge gekommen da in den, äh, Zionistenheim bei Genf. Und für mich und für mein Kind, und für meinen Mann haben sie schon gezahlt, aber sehr, sehr schwer. Einen Monat.
David Boder: Und Sie haben privat gewohnt?
Malka Johles: Dann hab’ ich, erst hab` ich gewohnt bis Februar ´43, hab’ ich gewohnt im Hotel und dann hat man mich, muss ich eine möblierte Wohnung nehmen.
David Boder: Nun?
Malka Johles: Keine leere Wohnung. Dann haben wir uns eine möblierte Wohnung gemietet...
David Boder: Unmöbilierte?
Malka Johles: Möblierte.
David Boder: Möblierte.
Malka Johles: Nur möblierte. Ja!
David Boder: Waren da Wohnungen zu mieten? Es waren doch so viele Menschen.
Malka Johles: Es waren, waren vielleicht, äh... In jeder Gasse waren vielleicht, äh, fünfzig, sechzig Wohnungen.
David Boder: Wieso waren...?
Malka Johles: Bei jeder Gasse!
David Boder: Wie erklären Sie, dass da keine...?
Malka Johles: Nun, jetzt ist keine zu haben. Jetzt leider wohn ich möbliert. Auch möbliert.
David Boder: Aha, nun?
Malka Johles: Und dann hat man, im März, hat man uns noch gezahlt, im April hat’s geheissen, dass nur mein, mein Mann kann man nicht mehr unterstützen, nur ich, weil ich bin untersucht worden von dem Doktor, dass ich krank bin... Vom polnischen Doktor.
David Boder: Aber ihr Mann war doch auch krank.
Malka Johles: Mein Mann haben Sie gesagt, können sie nicht zahlen. Das hat die Komitee Zürich getan für meinen Mann. Für mich und für’s Kind hat das polnische Konsulat gezahlt. Bis zum 20. August, äh, August. ´43.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Am 20. August ´43 hab’ ich bekommen eine Tele-[unverständlich], dass ich muss ins Lager, nach [unverständlich], das ist ganz an der Höhe, 1400 Meter hoch.
David Boder: Hmm...mit dem Kind.
Malka Johles: Bei Montreux, mit dem Kind und mein Mann war im Arbeitslager. Hier, [unverständlich]. Das ist bei St. Moritz.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Nicht, das andere St. Moritz.
Malka Johles: Kennen sie die Gegend? Nein.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Im Arbeitslager war mein Mann dort.
David Boder: Und was haben die dort gearbeitet?
Malka Johles: Mein Mann hat müssen, in der, bei der, in der Erde, herausnehmen, die, die, die ganzen, ganzen Sachen, die, wie heissen die... die Wurzeln...
David Boder: Die Bäume?
Malka Johles: Die Bäume... ja.
David Boder: Die Wurzeln von den Bäumen.
Malka Johles: Ja. Ja. Und da war ich vom einundzwanzigsten August bis zum siebenundzwanzi...bis zum siebzehnten November war ich in [unverständlich].
David Boder: Nun.
Malka Johles: Und dann bin ich gekommen ins Spital.
David Boder: Warum?
Malka Johles: Ich? Bin ich gelegen, äh, drei Wochen in der Frauensp... klinik,
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Maternité. Und dann bin, bin ich auch, äh, operiert worden, eine kleine Operation, eine Frauenoperation.
Malka Johles: Und dann bin ich am achtzehnten Dezember auf dem Kropf operiert worden und dann war ich bis zum zwölften Jänner `44 im Spital.Veraltete Bezeichnung für „Januar“ (Anmerk. d.R)8
David Boder: Wer hat Sie vor dem Kropf operiert?
Malka Johles: Den Kropf?
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Äh, ich weiß nicht, wie das, wie der, äh,
David Boder: Wussten Sie doch....
Malka Johles: [unverständlich] hat er doch geheißen, ich glaube Fischer irgend..., nicht der Professor. Ich habe gefragt das Professor. Haben sie gesagt, wir haben auch andere Ärzte, nicht nur..
David Boder: Ja, aber die haben sie doch sehr gut operiert.
Malka Johles: Sehr gut, ja.
David Boder: She is, she was operated from a [unverständlich] goiter. And, err, there is hardly a scar to be noticed. Hardly. It is a wonderful suture. And, err, one absolutely must search for it, must search for the scar to identify it. Nun? Äh, und dann wo, weiter?
Malka Johles: War ich ein Monat hier.
David Boder: Und wo war der Junge?
Malka Johles: Mein Junge war in Roberto, bei Genf, im Zionistenheim.
David Boder: Im Zionistenheim.
Malka Johles: Ja. Tertiär.Evtl. ist die dritte Jahrgangsstufe der (Schul)Ausbildung gemeint. (Anmerk.d.R.)9
David Boder: Und was hat er dort getan?
Malka Johles: Gelernt und Schul....dann
David Boder: Was?
Malka Johles: Ist er gewesen, äh...
David Boder: Hat man ihn ein Fach gelehrt?
Malka Johles: Nachher erst.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Im, äh, da in Genf.
Malka Johles: In der ORT.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Ja. Im März, äh, ´44 hat er erst angefangen. Ein Jahr später.
David Boder: Ein Jahr später. Was haben Sie studie...
Malka Johles: [unverständlich]
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: Und, äh, war er, wo ist der Junge jetzt?
Malka Johles: Der Junge ist jetzt in, äh, bei Tel Aviv.
David Boder: Der Junge ist jetzt bei Tel Aviv. Ist er leg..
Malka Johles: Voriges Jahr weggefahren.
David Boder: Ist er legal darein gek...?
Malka Johles: Legal. Und sehr froh auf. Mit der Alía.
David Boder: Von wo? Von (unverständlich, klingt wie „Paschem“, eine Ortsbezeichnung)?
Malka Johles: (Unverständlich, klingt wie „Werzua“, eine Ortsbezeichnung).
David Boder: Von Werzua, mit der Jugendalía, haben Sie ihn...
Malka Johles: Ja, am 28. Mai...
David Boder: Und was tut er in Palästina?
Malka Johles: Na, Kibbutz.
David Boder: Äh, arbeitet er schon lange?
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter.
Malka Johles: Mit den Blumen, arbeit’ er.
David Boder: Ja, aber sagen Sie mir, was hat er hier vom ORT gelernt?
Malka Johles: Gelernt, äh, Schlosserei.
David Boder: Aber er ist kein Schlosser in Palästina.
Malka Johles: Äh, äh, es ist ihm versprochen worden, er wird, könne jetzt arbeiten, im Opania. Vielleicht in einer Schlosserei.
David Boder: Also, in, äh, in einer Schlosserei.
Malka Johles: Ja. Opania bei Tel Aviv.
David Boder: Und, äh, verdienen tut er selbständig?
Malka Johles: Nein, nein. Er ist im Kibbutz.
David Boder: Ein Kibbutz ist was?
Malka Johles: Dort lebt er, das ist eine so, so Heim, so, so...
David Boder: Eine Kooperative.
Malka Johles: So Kooperative dort, äh, wird ihm gesorgt.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Dort isst er und schlaft und hat sein Essen und, und lernt.
David Boder: Ja. Nun, was wollen Sie tun?
Malka Johles: Ich will nach Amerika. Weil...
David Boder: Sie wollen nicht nach Palästina?
Malka Johles: Ich hab’ keine Aussicht jetzt. Jetzt ist keine Aussicht. Ich wollte ja nach Palästina.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Aber leider.
David Boder: Und, und sie lehren sich jetzt was?
Malka Johles: Auch da, in dem, in dem...ORT..
David Boder: Hier im ORT und Sie nehmen, Sie lernen Stricken.
Malka Johles: Stricken, auch mein Mann.
David Boder: Und auch Ihr Mann.
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: Lernen Stricken.
David Boder: Und wovon leben Sie jetzt?
Malka Johles: Jetzt bekommen wir von der Hand vom Komitee.
David Boder: Vom welchen? Vom jüdischen.
Malka Johles: Vom jüdischen Komitee.
David Boder: Ist das genug zum Leben?
Malka Johles: Nun...
David Boder: Man muss auskommen.
Malka Johles: Es ist besser wie, wie im Lager, nicht wahr?
David Boder: Besser wie im Lager.
Malka Johles: Im Lager, weil ich meine, es ist jetzt schon eine andere Zeit. Wo man, eines andere Stelle [unverständlich] Schatten, jetzt möchte man schon gerne, etwas anderes, nicht dass man im Lager ist...
David Boder: Was heisst, man sieht den Schatten nicht?
Malka Johles: Man sieht ein, man sieht schon ein anderes Bild. Nicht, nicht, nicht, äh, Lagerleben.
David Boder: Ja. Und man will auch..
Malka Johles: Nicht im Lager leben.
David Boder: Und man will auch selbst was?
Malka Johles: Man möcht’ ja gerne auch einen Beruf lernen, was man einfach kann, wenn man kommt nach Amerika oder wohin..
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Ist doch sehr praktisch.
David Boder: Nun, äh, sagen Sie, wie geht es Ihrem Mann mit seiner Gesundheit jetzt?
Malka Johles: Danke, er ist zufrieden.
David Boder: Also, die Operation hat ihm geholfen.
Malka Johles: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Sprechen Sie lauter, bitte.
Malka Johles: Die Operation hat ihm geholfen.
David Boder: Man hat ihn in Frankreich operiert.
Malka Johles: Frankreich, in Saint-Julien, ja. Am 24. August.
David Boder: Und er hat diese Operation nicht bezahlen müssen.
Malka Johles: Nein, er war doch einkorporiert. Das heisst, er hat, äh..
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Im Arbeiterlager war er doch!
David Boder: Er war im Arbeiterlager.
Malka Johles: Das hat doch gezahlt die Krankenkasse. Die Präfektia.
David Boder: Nun, ist da etwas, was Sie, äh, noch sagen wollten?
Malka Johles: (Stille)
David Boder: Wie, äh, sagen Sie, Sie haben Ihren Affidavit wie lange schon?
Malka Johles: Wir haben schon in Wien ein Affidavit gehabt, in Lyon haben wir schon eine Visazusage gehabt, habt. Im 42er Jahr, im August. Und jetzt hab’ ich im Oktober auch schon von Washington, äh, Oktober, äh, ´45 hab’ ich von Washington bekommen, auch eine Visazusage.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Da schreibt eben mein Mann seine Schwester. Ob wir nicht da ein Vorzug haben können. Weil wir schon im Oktober voriges Jahr, die, die, die Visazusage gehabt haben. Ob wir nicht heuer... irgend begünstigt werden können. Bei der Quote.
David Boder: Das hat Ihre Schwester geschrieben?
Malka Johles: Ja, von meinem Mann die Schwester.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Wir haben sie doch, wir, ich hab’ sie doch da schriftlich die Visazusage. Von Washington.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und jetzt haben wir erst im Mai von Zürich bekommen die Visazusage.
David Boder: Nun?
Malka Johles: Aber, das... Mein Schwager meint, warum, warum, äh, dass wir nicht, äh, sich, darum kümmern in Zürich. Ob wir nicht können da begünstigt werden. Bei der Quote, weil wir schon haben von Washington auch voriges Jahr.
David Boder: Wo ist ihr, äh...
Malka Johles: Mein Mann seine Schwester?
David Boder: Ja, wo ist sie?
Malka Johles: In New York. Ich geb` Ihnen, ich weiss nicht, ich hab’ nicht...
David Boder: Sie werden mir später die Adresse aufschreiben.
Malka Johles: Ich hab’ alle Adresse.
David Boder: Und was sagt der Konsul hier zu?
Malka Johles: Der Konsul sagt, dass, dass ich hab’ von Washington von voriges Jahr. Das hab’ ich ihm eingeschickt. Und da schrei-, (verbessert sich) sagt er, das war eben ein Fehler von den Affidavit-Gebern. Statt er hätt` sollen schon nach Zürich einreichen voriges Jahr, hat er eingereicht nach Washington. Und das gilt nicht.
David Boder: Aha. Und, äh...
Malka Johles: Da, äh, da kann ich keine Begünstigung haben.
David Boder: Und hat er jetzt nach Zürich eingereicht?
Malka Johles: Ja, wir haben doch schon...
David Boder: Und was hat er gesagt, der [unverständlich] ...
Malka Johles: (Unterbricht) Visazusage haben wir schon im Mai.
David Boder: [unverständlich] Quote sein?
Malka Johles: Sie haben uns geschrieben vorige Woche, haben sie uns bestätigt, die, wir haben eingeschickt, äh, noch im Mai. Die Bilder und Dokumente und alles. Haben sie uns erst vorige Woche, nach vier Monate bestätigt, dass wir haben es erhalten und sollt` ich sofort, äh, hereinkommen, so wird, äh, werden wir, kommen wir dran. Papiere sind gut.
David Boder: Ja, ich glaub die sind ein bisschen langsam, weil es doch überhaupt noch keine Schiffe gibt.
Malka Johles: Gibt schon Schiffe, wenn nur die Quoten wären...
David Boder: Na ja, darum halten sie die...
Malka Johles: Würden wir schon schauen...
David Boder: Na ja, die halten die Quoten zurück, weil sie keine Schiffe haben, zum Beispiel...
Malka Johles: Das weiß ich nicht, aber jedenfalls...
David Boder: Das wissen Sie nicht.... Äh, hat der Konsul sich gedacht....[unverständlich]...
Malka Johles: Voriges Jahr haben wir Aussicht gehabt nach Palästina zu fahren und nach Amerika. Und jetzt haben wir leider, wir können nicht so lange warten, bis wir nach Palästina kommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Ein Leben nicht. Und da möchten wir schon doch, doch nach Amerika...[unverständlich].
David Boder: Nun ja, aber vielleicht Ihre, äh, Ihr Leute von Boston...
Malka Johles: Ach, die haben doch... [unverständlich]
David Boder: Und von New York, wenn die mit ihrem Senator oder irgendwen oder der [unverständlich] betreut, der hat Ihnen auch ein Affidavit gegeben?
Malka Johles: Der hat uns und von meinem Mann die Schwester hat etwas einen Teil schon dazu dazugegeben. Da sie wollte schon, dass wir schon einmal recht sein. Hat sie auch schon eins dazugegeben. Sie ist selbst ein Flüchtling. Sie ist erst von Brüssel weggefahren.
David Boder: Nach Amerika.
Malka Johles: Nach Amerika. Von Brüssel [unverständlich].
David Boder: Ist sie allein oder ist sie...
Malka Johles: Hat über Johles aufge... [unverständlich]... hat Name... [unverständlich].... Nein, und
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Sie hat zwei Kinder so....
David Boder: So.
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: Nun, ich glaube....
Malka Johles: Mein Mann beschwert sich, dass, dass....
David Boder: Mit so vielen Leuten, die für sie was tun können, wird das schon ganz plötzlich kommen. Einen Morgen werden Sie das bekommen und werden in, äh, einer Woche oder zwei wegkommen müssen sie gehen. Wenn...
Malka Johles: Man wird ja doch, wie man sagt, was einmal so lange dauert, ist schon wie ein Krebs. [unverständlich] Das ist doch schon, noch und noch, und jetzt ist man da von heut auf morgen, geplagt...
David Boder: Äh, haben Sie eine möblierte Wohnung jetzt?
Malka Johles: Leider möbliert.
David Boder: Warum leider.
Malka Johles: Leider, weil ich weiß nicht, die kommt nach Hause Samstag die Frau, ob sie mir [unverständlich] gegeben.
David Boder: Oh, das ist es. Die Frau ist weggegangen und Sie haben...
Malka Johles: Weggefah...Nein, sie ist auf, äh, sie arbeitet auf Küchen, auf der, auf dem Lande. Jetzt hat sie mir schon vorher aufgesagt, sie braucht sie für eine Freundin. Sie kommt von Deutschland und so. Also, ich weiß nicht, ob es wird nicht...
David Boder: Was zahlen Sie für die Wohnung?
Malka Johles: Ich zahl’ fünfundsiebzig Franken.
David Boder: 75 Franken monatlich?
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: Das ist ja...
Malka Johles: Ein kleines schmales, äh, so schmal, vielleicht noch schmäler und kleiner.
David Boder: Ein Zimmer.
Malka Johles: Mit ein Fenster. Mit Küchenbenutzung.
David Boder: Ach und mit [unverständlich]...
Malka Johles: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Wann haben Sie Zeit zu kochen, wenn Sie hier zu [unverständlich]...
Malka Johles: Ich arbeite nur nachmittags. Ich hab’ doch ein Kind, ich hab doch ein Kind!
David Boder: Oh, sie arbeiten nur nachmittags. Und wo ist die Kleine?
Malka Johles: Meine Kleine kommt morgen zurück. Von...
David Boder: Wo ist sie?
Malka Johles: Bei Zürich, bei meinem Mann seine Schwester. Sie wohnt beim Land. Auch auf... [unverständlich] aber sie wohnt bei [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Wie ist Ihrem Manns Schwester nach, äh, Schweiz gekommen?
Malka Johles: Auch, äh, zugleich mit uns, zugleich mit uns.
David Boder: Sie ist zugleich mit Ihnen die Grenze rüber...
Malka Johles: Ja, wir haben viel mitgemacht an der Grenze. Aber, äh, Gott sei Dank, ist es, äh, Hauptsache wir sind angekommen. Auf dem Weg ist ein Malheur geschehen.
David Boder: Was ist passiert?
Malka Johles: Es ist geschehen, ach Gott, äh, lange [unverständlich].
David Boder: Nu, was ist dann...
Malka Johles: Wir haben gemietet einen Krankenwagen...auto in Annecy...
David Boder: Wer [unverständlich]...
Malka Johles: Ja. Bis zu der, bis zu dem Führer.
David Boder: Warten Sie mal...
Malka Johles: Bis zu dem Führer.
David Boder: Ein Moment bitte.
Malka Johles: Damit wir nicht brauchen den Autobus fahren.
David Boder: Warten Sie mal.
Malka Johles: Ja. Damit wir nicht den Autobus... [unverständlich]. In den Autobus einzusteigen, war sehr gefährlich.
David Boder: ...Warten Sie einen Moment.
Malka Johles: Ja.
Malka Johles: Kann man nicht verst...viel erzählen, mein lieber Herr (?)
David Boder: Warum nicht?
Malka Johles: Ach, das ist viel zu erzählen.
David Boder: Ja, was wollen Sie denn die wissen?
Malka Johles: (Unverständlich, uns?)
David Boder: Na sehen Sie, wenn man das nicht erzählt, dann denkt man, ja, um Gottes Willen, die Leute leben ja dort, die werden unterstützt, was muss sie... [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Da. [unverständlich] (hebt die Stimme; wird lauter, oder so) sollen Sie erleben, [unverständlich] wenn man auf, auf Kisten sitzt.
David Boder: [In English] This is spool 90, Mrs. Malka Johles continues.
David Boder: [In German] Also sagen Sie, ich wollte wissen, Sie haben damals gesagt, wie Sie die Grenze...
Malka Johles: Ja. Wir sind gekommen nach Annecy.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Das ist schon nicht weit von der Grenze. Und da hat man uns empfohlen, da haben wir sehr Angst gehabt, einzusteigen in einen Autobus.
Malka Johles: Es hat geheissen, das ist gefährlich.
David Boder: Und wie sind Sie nach, äh, das, äh, wie hat die Stadt gehiessen, wo Sie waren?
Malka Johles: Annecy. Annecy.
David Boder: Und wie sind Sie nach Annecy gekommen?
Malka Johles: Annecy, mein Mann hat doch die Bestätigung gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Da hat man ihn ge... [unverständlich], hat er gesagt, äh, dann, äh, hätt` jemand gefragt, hätt’ er gesagt, er fährt ins Spital zum verbinden, weil...
David Boder: Ja. Und Sie waren...
Malka Johles: [unverständlich]. Ja, und ich wär mitge..., ich bin mitgefahren mit meinem Mann als Begleiter.
David Boder: Und die Kinder.
Malka Johles: Und die Kinder. Aber...
David Boder: Und wer noch? Eine Schwester von wem?
Malka Johles: Von meinem Mann.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Mit einem Kinden.
David Boder: Und die ist jetzt in der Schweiz.
Malka Johles: Die ist jetzt in der Schweiz, bei Zürich.
David Boder: Also sind Sie gefahren, sechs Personen und einen...
Malka Johles: Die Familie, was man zurückgeschickt hat.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Nein. Und gefahren....
Malka Johles: Und wir haben gehabt, äh, das äh, das französische Papier.
David Boder: Die andere Familie?
Malka Johles: Den andere Familie.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Malka Johles: Ich habe nichts gehabt. Nur mein Mann hat gehabt die.
David Boder: Seine Papiere....
Malka Johles: Bestätigung, Papiere, dass er, dass er vom Spital operiert worden und hat dann, äh, Krankenurlaub für einen Monat, hätt’, sollt man ihn [unverständlich] Autobus oder was er fahren? Hat er gesagt, dass er hat, äh....
David Boder: Und wie sind Sie gefahren, bei Autobus?
Malka Johles: Nein, wir sind gefahren bei Bahn.
David Boder: Mit der Bahn.
Malka Johles: Bis nach Annecy.
David Boder: Wie viel Stunden hat das gedauert.
Malka Johles: Das hat gedauert, glaub ich, vier Stunden.
David Boder: Nun?
Malka Johles: In Annecy ist mein Mann doch gefahren bis zum dem Führer...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: In dem Autobus eingestiegen...
Malka Johles: Mit den kleinem Mäderl.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Zu dem Führer, wir hatten einen Führer, der war halt unser [unverständlich]... ein paar Tage.
David Boder: Ah, Sie hatten einen Führer, der...
Malka Johles: Mein Mann hat gesagt...
David Boder: Ein “guide”...
Malka Johles: Ein, ja. Äh, mein Mann hat gesagt, er hat keine Angst, weil des, wo der Führer ist, ist nicht weit von St. Julien.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Wollt man ihn, er hat eine Kontrolle, sagt er, er fahrt ...
David Boder: Nach St. Julien.
Malka Johles: St. Julien. Ins Spital. Wir haben Angst gehabt, und da waren wir vier Tage in Annecy. Versteckt, in ein Hotel.
David Boder: In Annecy?
Malka Johles: Annecy.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Das ist nicht weit von Annemasse von der Grenze.Dept. Haute Savoie.10 Und da haben wir nicht gewusst, was wir sollen machen. Diese Familie, was man zurückgeschickt hat, die hatten einen Bekannten gehabt in Annecy. Und der hat uns geschickt, äh, jemanden, und der hat uns empfohlen, dass man soll uns einen Krankenwagen ausergeben.
David Boder: Oh! Ein Ambulanz.
Malka Johles: Das heisst, ein Arzt, ein Ambulanz. Und, als erste Partie ist gefahren, die Familie, was man zurückgeschickt hat. Sie mit dem Sohn...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und der Mann.
Malka Johles: Äh, drei Personen. Ich mit meiner Schwägerin...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und mit das Kind, ist geblieben.
Malka Johles: Wenn, wenn, äh, dort in dem Spital. Und wir haben gewart bist der Wagen kommt...
David Boder: Zurück?
Malka Johles: Zurück. Mein Junge, mein Junge....
David Boder: Wieviel Zeit ist... [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Ist eingestiegen in Autobus und ist auch gefahren zu dem Führer. Er hat gesagt, er, er bleibt nicht im Annecy im Hotel, er hat keine Angst nicht. Er kann perfekt Französisch und richtig ist er dort ja angekommen zu meinem Mann, zu dem Führer. Dort haben wir...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Äh...
David Boder: Haben Sie sich gesehen...
Malka Johles: Wir haben uns doch müssen warten dort.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Und mein Junge ist gekommen und sagt meinen Mann, warum bist du nicht, warum hast du nicht die Mama mitgenommen? Und die Tante? Sagt er, die haben Angst gehabt. Und zufällig war keine Kontrolle im Autobus.
David Boder: Hmm.
Malka Johles: Na... Gut ist. Also, wir haben etwas bezahlt, für den Kranken... Für den Ambulanz... Sie verstehen...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und, die sind als erstes gefahren. Der, äh die Familie...
David Boder: Die andere Familie.
Malka Johles: Die andere Familie. Und wir warten schon. Gott sei Dank. Also, wir... ja, mit dem ersten, mit dem ersten, äh... Partie, ist der Führer auch mitge... der ist gekommen nach.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Uns abholen. Und der ist mitgefahren mit dieser Familie.
Malka Johles: Er ist gesessen auf dem Bob [unverständlich] bei dem Chauffeur. Und wir haben gewartet. Der Chauffeur hat das schon gewusst, wo er braucht... wo er die Leute ablassen.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Dass sie zu uns müssen. Und wie er richtig er gekommen, zu der richtigen Minute, zurück. Und wir sind eingestiegen, und wir sind auch gefahren mit dem Ambulanz.
Malka Johles: Bis zu dem Führer.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und dann [unverständlich]... der sollte uns dann rüberführen. Das war ein Schweizer. Und der hat gelebt in Frankreich, hat er doch die Wege gewusst, die Wälder und das alles. Also, ein armer Teufel mit fünf oder sechs Kindern. Auf einmal, das Auto, das Auto, das Ambulanzwagen bleibt stehen, kommt mein Mann heraus, sagt er, Kinder, schreckt euch nicht. Es ist etwas geschehen.
David Boder: Was ist geschehen?
Malka Johles: (Pause) Schreckt euch nicht. Wir kommen herein, steigt einmal aus. Wir kommen herein, stehen, äh, fünfzeh... Gendarmenristen.Das Wort, das sie benutzt klingt wie „Gendarmeristen“ oder „Gardemobilisten“.11 Bei dem Führer in der Wohnung.
David Boder: Nun.
Malka Johles: Es war nämlich so. Das Autobus hat, äh, die Gardemobilisten sind vorher angekommen und haben wollen fahren nach St. Julien, diese Strecke...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und das Autobus hat verspätet gegehabt. Und die, die Gardemobilisten, die war... die Gendarme haben bemerkt, wir steigt aus bei dem Führer. Wer sind die Leute?
David Boder: Von Ambulanz.
Malka Johles: Von Ambulanz! Sind die hereingekommen. Der Junge ist heraus, der, äh, mit dreiundzwanzig Jahr, ist heraus, äh, auf dem Baum, hat sich versteckt. Die Frau ist wieder herein (in eine Grube?), die konnte nicht mehr herein. Mein Mann ist heraus mit dem ledernen, mit dem Jungen auf dem Boden. Haben sie gesagt, wann wir nicht alle herauskommt, fangen sie an zu schießen. Also, die Frau...
David Boder: Waren das französische Gardemobilisten ?
Malka Johles: Französisch, ja. Und der Gardemobilist, das war ein Unglücksfall. Dass gerade das Autobus verweilt hat und die haben gewartet an der Haltestalle und haben bemerkt, da ist etwas nicht koscher. Also, man hat angefangen zu weinen. Alle sechs Kinder von dem, von dem Passeur, mein Mann hat geweint, ja.Anm.: Jemand, der Menschen über die Grenze schmuggelt.12 Und der hat müssen zurückkommen vom Baum...
David Boder: Wer? Der... ihr Sohn?
Malka Johles: Der Junge. Nein, nicht, äh, der, der, äh, Junge.
David Boder: [unverständlich]... von den, von der anderen...
Malka Johles: Von der Familie. Ja. Was als erstes gefahren ist. Hat angefangen zu weinen, hat ange... Die Frau ist, äh, in Ohnmacht gefahren. Hat man sie angefangen zu retten, also. Die hat aber einen Sohn in Zürich, der die kennt in Tunis...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Die, die eine Familie. Hat sie ihm gezeigt, äh, den Marokko, ein französischer Soldat. Hat sie herausgenommen, das gezeigt, die Soldaten das zu schauen, mein Sohn ist doch auch ein französischer Soldat. Und der Mann, ist doch krank, mit einen Aut..., einem Auto. Dann hat sie [unverständlich]... abgekauft. Haben gesagt...
David Boder: Die Gardemobilisten...
Malka Johles: Die Gardemobilisten. Haben heruntergenommen alles, was wir hatten.
David Boder: Dass man gehabt [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Ja. Und geschmacklos alles hat gegeben. Sonst hätten sie uns doch gewesen...
David Boder: Was hat man dort weggegeben?
Malka Johles: Die Uhren, was man hat gehabt. Der, der, äh, [unverständlich] hat, äh, eine Uhr gegeben. Und die Frau. Was man halt gehabt. Also haben sie gesagt, jetzt hat der Führer gesagt, jetzt kommt noch eine Partie...
David Boder: Ja, ja.
Malka Johles: Wir! Also haben sie gesagt, man soll sich nicht schrecken und die sind, äh, haben uns noch gewünscht eine gute, gute...
David Boder: Reise.
Malka Johles: Reise. Und haben die Ehre gegeben. Der, der eine hat also gesagt, das schwer ist für seine Mutter. Wir haben geglaubt, die gehen heraus und werden uns erst anzeigen.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Haben sie gesagt, ihr braucht keine Angst zu haben. Ihr könnt’s da bleiben bis bei der Nacht, weil bei Tag kann man doch nicht durchgehen durch die Grenze.
Malka Johles: Und hab’ ich schon Angst gehabt zu bleiben bei dem Führer.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Sie verstehen? Vielleicht gehen sie heraus und, und, äh, schicken dann ein andern, äh, Gendarme. Haben sie, der eine gesprochen bei seiner Mutter, dass er wird das nicht tun. Er wird nix machen. Wir können ruhig sitzen bis bei der Nacht. Bis zwölf Uhr bei der Nacht ist, und dann können wir gehen. Und der Führer hat eben auch angefangen. Das war doch ein, ein, äh, Schweizer. Und der hat gewohnt in Frankreich. Hätt’, hätten die ihn doch eingesperrt. Ihn auch.
Malka Johles: Hat er gesagt, Nein, er tut uns nix. Und der hat uns gelassen. Verstehen Sie mich?
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und dann sollten wir doch hinüber. Auf dem Weg dorthin haben wir niemanden getroffen. Also, so haben wir halt gehabt...
David Boder: Wie hat [unverständlich]. Welchen Weg? Wie lang hat das gedauert?
Malka Johles: Welchen Weg... Na, vier Stunden... oder fünf Stunden.
David Boder: Vier Stunden hat das gedauert!
Malka Johles: Ach! Plus Regen und...
David Boder: Also war das wirklich auf diesem einen Weg...
Malka Johles: Mein Mann nach der Operation... Selbstverständlich. Mein Mann nach der Operation, ja...
David Boder: Ihr Mann hatte den Leistenbruch gehabt.
Malka Johles: Nach der Operation. Das war ja von, äh, einen Monat, ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Nicht einmal einen Monat. Am zweiundzwanzigsten sind wir weggefahren, es war ja nach dem [unverständlich]... gleichen Tag, nach dem [unverständlich].
David Boder: Und der hat, sobald man rübergewesen ist, hat man (unverständlich; kommen können, zur Schweizer und hat Papiere? Bekommen/ rüber gekommen)...
Malka Johles: Ja. Wir hatten, wir sind geheim gekommen, haben wir gesehen nichts.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Dann haben wir gar nicht gewusst, ob wir schon am Schweizer Border sind. Hat mein Mann ein kleines Lamperl, Lampe gehabt. Wir sind gegangen hin, gegangen her. Und dann haben wir doch... Der Führer durft doch nicht die Schw..., äh, Franzö... die Schweizer Grenze passieren. Sonst würden sie ihn doch einsperren.
Malka Johles: Haben... Als Schweizer, der fährt doch nicht nach Schweiz zurück, wann er lebt in Frankreich...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Hat er uns nur gezeigt. Da sind wir hernübergehen über das Wasser und der hat uns ein bissle explikiert, ein bissle aufgeklärt...
David Boder: Hmm.
Malka Johles: Natürlich, einmal haben wir einen Weg angeschlagen, wären wir grad gekommen zu der Gestapo. Wären wir grad gekommen gewesen zu den Franzosen...
David Boder: Nun? Und wie haben Sie ...
Malka Johles: Hat mein Mann gesagt, wir gehen nicht herunter, geh herauf!
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und wir sind heraufgegangen. Und richtig sind wir gekommen. Haben wir auf einmal schon gesehen. Eine, eine, eine französische Tafel...
David Boder: Eine was?... äh, äh, Schweizer!
Malka Johles: Ah, Schweizer Tafel! Dann haben wir gesehen eine Wohnung mit Licht.
David Boder: Hmm.
Malka Johles: Licht. Haben wir angeläutet. Und heraus kam ein Herr, sagt er, kommt nur herein, sagt er, ihr seid schon am Schweizer Boden. Ich lasse eigens zu diesem Zwecke das Licht brennen, damit wenn die Leute kommen durch der Grenze, dass sie hereinkommen können. Hereinkommen, hat er uns ... die Kleider abgenommen, die waren ganz nass, hat uns ein Bad gemacht, hat uns gegeben Kaffee und alles. Natürlich die Kleider getrocknet ein bissle am Ofen und inzwischen hat er aber auch verständigt die Polizei. Manche erwischt man...
David Boder: Warum? Warum hat er es?
Malka Johles: Äh, äh, musst er. Manche, äh...
David Boder: [unverständlich]... Warum hat er...
Malka Johles: (Unverständlich; aufgeregt)... auf dem, auf dem Weg. Uns hat man nicht erwischt auf dem Weg. Wir hat... Konnten sogar bis nach Genf kommen.
David Boder: Aber, wer war der Mann, dass er sie so aufgenommen hat?
Malka Johles: Der, ein, äh, ein Schweizer.
David Boder: Privatperson?
Malka Johles: Privatperson. Aber er musst sofort verständigen die Polizei...
David Boder: Nun ja, das ist ja klar...
Malka Johles: Die kommen sofort von der Polizei, der Herr mit dem Radl. Und er hat gesagt, wir sollen noch ein bissl sich aufwärmen und wir sollen uns sich noch ein bissl beruhigen. Und er geht mit uns mit. Wir sind hingekommen am Kommissariat. Für das Ganze vielleicht 20 Minuten. Hat er alles aufgenommen, was wir haben gehabt, die Personal und die paar Groschen, was wir haben gehabt. Und...
David Boder: Was heißt “aufgenommen”? Aufgeschrieben, nicht. Die haben nichts zugenommen
Malka Johles: Ja... und dann haben sie es uns... zurückgegeben.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Aber, bei dieser Familie haben sie gesagt, dass sollen auch das Rasierzeug und alles herausgeben. Und dann auf einmal hat er gesagt, die Familie soll wieder zurücknehmen.
David Boder: Hmm.
Malka Johles: Hat er gesagt, warum, warum soll ich’s wieder zurücknehmen, ich geb’s doch ihnen, sagt er, ich habe doch keine Angst, nicht. Sagt er, nein, nehmen Sie sich Ihr Geld nur zusammen und hat sie leider...
David Boder: Zurückgeschickt.
Malka Johles: Zurückgeschickt. Also, das können Sie sich nicht vorstellen.
David Boder: Bei dieser Familie?
Malka Johles: Ja. Das ist [unverständlich]
David Boder: Nun?
Malka Johles: Ja. Und uns... wir sind da...
David Boder: Nachher sind Sie rüber, doch rübergekommen.
Malka Johles: Ja. Viermal. Viermal.
David Boder: Haben Sie sie getroffen?
Malka Johles: Ja, die waren bei uns in Genf. Ja.
David Boder: Aha. Und zuletzt hat man sie rübergelassen.
Malka Johles: Ja, zuletzt sind sie doch gekommen. Also, wir sind gekommen, haben wir Glück gehabt. Natürlich viele hat man erwischt direkt an der Grenze. Uns egal. Und dies, wir haben uns allein gemeldet. Wir sind da rein doch für die Familie und die Familien angerufen, die Police und da hat man uns von dort abgeholt, da waren wir und waren wir einen Tag und dann...
David Boder: Haben Sie nachher die Leute gesehen? Wissen Sie wo, wer die Leute sind, die Sie aufgenommen haben?
Malka Johles: Na, auf’m Kommissariat...
David Boder: Nein, nein, die, nein, nein, die, äh, Familie, die, äh, die sie zuerst aufgenommen hat...
Malka Johles: Ja, ich glaube. Mein Junge sagt, er hat ihn einmal gesehen.
David Boder: Hat ihn einmal gesehen.
Malka Johles: Ja. Wie sie heißen genau weiß ich nicht. Da kamen wir nach Genf und..
David Boder: Also soweit... Soweit haben Sie Glück gehabt. Soweit haben [unverständlich] Glück haben müssen... [unverständlich]
Malka Johles: Haben wir Glück gehabt. Ja. [unverständlich] Hier fehlt ein unverständlicher Satz von Fr. Johles
David Boder: Also, Sie wollen, dass Ihre Verwandten in Amerika sehen, dass Sie...
Malka Johles: Ja, die sollen irgendetwas machen. Ich meine...
David Boder: Wollen Sie mir den Namen Ihrer Schwester in Boston geben? Ihrer Schwägerin?
Malka Johles: Schwägerin... Rindler. Aber es ist auch [unverständlich]. Ich geb’ alles in meinen Ordner ein.
David Boder: [unverständlich] Sie geben uns bloß den Namen.
Malka Johles: Den Namen, äh, Is..., äh, Isaak Rindler. Von meinem Mann die Schwester, der Schwager.
David Boder: Der Schwager ist Isaak Rindler?
Malka Johles: Ja. Rindler.
David Boder: Rindler. R, I, N, D...
Malka Johles: R, I, N, D...
David Boder: N, D.
Malka Johles: Soll ich’s Ihnen aufschreiben?
David Boder: Äh, Isaak Rindler.
Malka Johles: Isaak Rindler. Er hat sie...
David Boder: Der lebt wo? In Boston?
Malka Johles: Ähm, nein, äh, der ist in New York. Bronx, glaub ich jetzt.
David Boder: Rindler.
Malka Johles: Ja. Ab jetzt....
David Boder: Bronx.
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: New York. Was für ein Geschäft hat er denn? Stickerei?
Malka Johles: Er hat jetzt ein Pelzgeschäft.
David Boder: Oh! Er hat ein Pelzgeschäft!
Malka Johles: Ja, oder compagnon od....
David Boder: Da kann man ihn [unverständlich]...
Malka Johles: [unverständlich] . Schreiben sie auch, der [unverständlich] Weiler.
David Boder: [unverständlich] Weiler.
Malka Johles: Weiler. Heißt der [unverständlich] Ich wäre mit dem [unverständlich]...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Alles geben.
Malka Johles: Alles.
David Boder: Der ist also in New York.
Malka Johles: Ja. Der ist erst im 40er Jahr Februar weggefahren.
David Boder: Und wen haben Sie in Boston?
Malka Johles: In Boston hab’ ich von meiner Schwester zwei, äh, zwei Kinder. Die eine heißt, äh, also die heißt Krauthammer...
David Boder: Hammert?
Malka Johles: Als ledig geheiss..., hat sie geheissen Krauthammer. Mein Schwager hat geheissen...
David Boder: Krauthammert?
Malka Johles: Krauthammer.
David Boder: Ja. Und?
Malka Johles: Dort leben zwei Onkel von sie. Von meinem Schwager zwei Brüder.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Gerschin und der andere war Krauthammer und der andere [unverständlich] mein Schwager der Bruder.
David Boder: Ja. Und die, äh, leben gut? Die machen ein gutes Leben dort?
Malka Johles: Wer?
David Boder: Ihre Verwandte?
Malka Johles: Meine Nichten? Sag ich doch, dass mein Schwager hat mir geschrieben, dass mein Neffe hat, äh, war, bei ihm. Und das ganze Gespräch hat gedauert fünf Minuten. Und er hat jetzt ein Zuschneider, ein Robenzuschneider.
David Boder: Ein [unverständlich]...aha...ja.
Malka Johles: Ja. Die jüngere Nicht... Die was ich verheiratet hab’ in Wien.
David Boder: Aha. Die Sie in Wien verheiratet?
Malka Johles: Die ich in Wien verheiratet hab’.
David Boder: Aha.
Malka Johles: Jawohl.
David Boder: Nun?
Malka Johles: Ist alles heilig. Die heisst, äh, Deutsch.
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Und die andere heisst, äh, Braun.
David Boder: Braun?
Malka Johles: Braun, ja.
David Boder: Beide leben in Boston?
Malka Johles: Beide in Boston.
David Boder: Werden Sie mir die Adressen aufschreiben...
Malka Johles: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Sehen Sie, ich kann Ihnen nichts versprechen, Frau Johles...
Malka Johles: Da ist da ein gewisser Greenberg.
David Boder: Wer ist das?
Malka Johles: Das ist von meiner, äh, von meiner Schwägerin, hat doch mein Bruder seine Frau deportiert geworden...
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: Eine Schwester. Von meiner Sch..., von meiner Schwägerin die Schwester.
David Boder: Ihren, Brud..., Ihren Bruders Frau ist deportiert geworden?
Malka Johles: [unverständlich] nur die Kinder, mit zwei Kindern und die Frau.
David Boder: Wo? In der [unverständlich].
Malka Johles: Aber eine Schwester wohnt in Boston und Ihr Onkel. Die wurden in deportiert bei, bei, bei Toulouse.
David Boder: Bei Tou...?
Malka Johles: Da sind sie gewesen die ganze Zeit.
David Boder: Von Toulouse wurden sie deportiert?
Malka Johles: Von...bei Toulouse, bei Toulouse. Sie waren nicht im Lager und sie waren nirgends... (einige Worte unverständlich) gutes Dorf gehabt. So sehr Unglück. Wollten Sie nicht nach Lyon... sind gesessen dort und haben gewartet auf Amerika.
David Boder: Hmm.
Malka Johles: Die haben da einen Onkel, meine Schwägerin. Der heisst Greenberg....
David Boder: Ja.
Malka Johles: In, äh, in, äh, in Boston.
Malka Johles: Und eine Schwester hat sie auch... Meine Schwäger hat eine Schwester. In Boston. Und die heißt auch Greenberg.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes, this concludes the interview with Miss Malka Johles...
Malka Johles: Ja.
David Boder: A case of a, err, err, refugee from Vienna to Belgium, from Belgium to, err, France, and finally, err, a refuge to Switzerland, where they have been taken, as, err, treated as victims of the war. And now they are waiting their, err, umm, trip to the United States. We can say that they have [unintelligible] the Anschluss in 1938. It’s now 1846 [1946]. And the story of their suffering and wandering is not yet over. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording, Geneva, August, the 28th, 1946.